khloe kardashian thanks a fan for
speaking out
in her defense i love it the 36 year old
reality star
commented on a viral tick tock video
posted by user mac and casey
who slams disparaging headlines
comparing a pick of coco from 2007
to a pic of her from present day isn't
that crazy
macking calls out the story saying chloe
worked quote
mad hard to look like she does today
working out is
one of my new obsession healthy
obsessions so yeah
the good american founder hit up the
comment section to share how it all
makes her feel
quote i don't want anyone to kiss my i'm
not asking for that
but what i am asking for is for people
to realize just what articles like this
does to someone's soul and confidence
chloe who has been open about her health
and wellness journey on keeping up with
the kardashians
and her show revenge body it's my
lifestyle
went on to thank the fan for his support
quote i am so
very grateful and appreciative of anyone
who stands up to bullying or people
writing stories
simply for click bait defending someone
especially when we don't know one
another
makes my heart happy that's the person i
am i like to defend what is right
thank you everyone for your sweet
comments and thank you mac and casey for
being so kind
and coco she's just staying focused on
bettering herself
back in 2019 she opened up to e.t about
working on herself
from the inside out i really think i'm
in a good place but i think working on
your personal growth internally is
something that will be a forever
mission and i always want to evolve and
grow and mature
emotionally because that's how we become
better
[Music]
people
you